life liberty pursuit of happiness
acquiring and possessing property free
exercise of religion sum up what it is
that human beings have by nature and
what they deserve to keep in other words
what they are rightfully able to claim
for themselves against other people you
might want to take that away because
their rights they're also duties if you
and I have a right to Liberty each of us
has a duty not to make the other a slave
property rights means that stealing is
forbidden if we possess the right to
life we have a duty not to commit murder
the founders sometimes formulated their
idea of natural rights in the language
of duty such as in the first sentence of
the Declaration of Independence the laws
of nature and of nature's God entitle
every nation to a separate and equal
station among the powers of the earth it
says there the laws of nature justify
national independence and forbid the
imperialistic domination of one nation
over other nations this is because all
men are created equal and all have the
same right to Liberty whether
individually or collectively